hello everyone my name is brian parman
i'm the ndsu agricultural finance
specialist
uh working for the department of ag
business and applied economics and ndsu
extension and today's presentation i
want to talk a bit about backgrounding
profits and returns for fall of 2021
headed into uh 2022
and this year we're dealing with
some different circumstances than we
have in the past with respect to uh
livestock particularly cattle prices
live cattle and feeder calves as well as
feed costs
things like hay
dry distillers grains corn those kind of
things crop commodity prices a bit
higher this year
but but we've had some strong livestock
prices this fall and as we go through
this we're going to see how this is
going to work out for
feeders potentially across north dakota
and the surrounding states
so for the uh scenarios that i'm running
here and that we're kind of going by
um these are the price assumptions that
we are working from this year and this
is
quite a bit different than last year uh
corn for instance we're assuming about
575 a bushel corn silage at 55 dollars a
ton dry distillers grains well above 200
a ton at 220.
most of the things like limestone
limestone bag salt and premix i didn't
change too much but hay prices uh are
are quite a bit higher
approaching 200 a ton for alfalfa hay
and 125 for grass hay
and then the yardage fee
we settled in on about 40 cents a day
for yardage
part of that due to the higher energy
costs that folks are facing this year
with higher natural gas prices
fuel prices things like that as well as
potentially electricity costs and then
trucking
last year's assumption was about 75
cents per hundred weight
increased it quite a bit almost 66
percent to a dollar 25 per hundred
weight
on the other hand interest
slightly down to about five percent
assumption and then shrink and death
loss staying roughly about the same
so this is kind of the price assumptions
here obviously as i go through this you
can adjust those in your mind a little
bit uh if you need to
if you think some of those are a little
bit too high perhaps too low
that that's just sort of a good
benchmark that uh we feel like that
we're running from here and so if if you
think again that some of these are are
off uh feel free kind of to to maybe
make a mental note and adjust them
accordingly
so
this are these are the six different
scenarios that we are uh running through
and that i'll be going through during
this presentation and we have
basically three steer and three heifer
backgrounding scenarios
um
one of which is the uh uh one 1.8 to two
pounds uh average daily gain for for
steers uh and these these animals start
at 500 pounds and are sold at 800 pounds
and this is the feed cost under those
assumptions that uh i was running
through per day so feed costs per per
pound
then the 2.8 pound scenario slightly
heavier
purchased heavier and sold a little bit
heavier that's 2.8 pound average daily
gain that's going to be about 60 cents
per day
or 60 cents per pound under that ration
scenario then a much faster daily gain
at 3.6 pounds a day and these are
starting at
575 pounds all the way out to about
finished and that comes out at about 64
cents a day
heifers we start with a scenario of
lighter weight heifers 450 up to 750 at
72 cents a day
then we have a 550 weight up to 850
weighted across the 77 cents per day and
then a 2.8 pound average daily gain for
heifers from 525 weight to 805 pounds at
a feed cost of approximately 59 cents
per day
so again i'm gonna so to start with i'm
gonna go through the uh steer feeding
scenarios first
and uh
then i'll go through the three heifer
scenarios after that and then we'll
compare uh compare all six
so this is the prices that we uh that
i'm i'm using for this presentation here
and this came from the north dakota
weekly auction summary ending uh the
weekend november 13th which
this is this recording is being made on
the 15th so this was friday uh last week
um and showing the the steer prices for
the for the
various ranges of weight and then i put
a live steer price there assumption at
the bottom so for for fat cattle at
about 131 dollars and 40 cents at 1350
pounds was the last report i saw for
some of the uh the buyers down in in
dakota city kind of area so these are
the assumptions working from here
for as far as the value of the animal
coming into your back grounding
operation and then the value that you
would be selling at at whatever the
weight happens to be 750 850 pounds etc
and note i use the average price here i
don't use a high and a low i'm just
simply using the the average price
because again this is an estimation
uh for these scenarios
so this is our first scenario uh we're
running here and this is that 500 weight
to 800 weight
steer
at 1.8 pounds per day this is the ration
being fed and you'll note here on this
this right column where it says dollar
per head per day that's not dollars per
pound so you'll note that uh
it's a dollar 30 per day and we i gave
uh the previous chart that showed the
price per pound this is a
you know the dollar
cost per day versus dollars per pound
assuming that 1.8 pound per day
scenario
so we put it through our our
backgrounding budget
estimator and i use the north dakota
state university backgrounding budget
and make some modifications to it
for instance if you open up the budget
you see online down below the return to
labor and management risk you'll see all
these prices for feed stuffs
i simply didn't use that because i
already did the ration assumption up
there so
for the sake of this presentation i just
put it in as the cost and you'll see the
feed cost of a dollar 30 per day
rather than rather than going and
filling out each individual item within
the ration
since i already showed what the ration
was you can you can see that and what we
have here in this scenario to get to
approximately 800 pounds that animal is
going to be on feed for 167 days
and with the lot cost and the shrink and
the trucking
our uh
total return over labor and management
is about minus eight dollars
and the biggest reason that this one
actually takes a loss and and this is
kind of the scenario for all the steer
scenarios is that the the current market
price of
feeder calves steers particularly that
550 weight uh
area
though those animals are are bringing a
relatively strong price
so in order for someone to make any
money
on on steers that 500 550 weight they're
going to have to put on more
weight faster than than 1.8 pounds per
day is is just kind of what this is
telling you so they're on weight long
enough here and and it just takes too
long it's just too slow and so
essentially there just isn't a big
return if we're not putting on the
weight on our steers fast enough so at
1.8 pounds that that steer
it just isn't generating the returns at
167 days on feed but you'll see going
forward
this back uh backgrounding and putting
on the weight at least on steers and
heifers as well
is a is a profitable situation going
forward
so our next scenario
we're running
575 weight animals to 855 pound animals
and this is again is a a
higher rate of gain 2.8 pounds per day
instead of that 1.8 that i that i had in
the last scenario uh total feed cost per
day is a bit higher uh because of the
fact that that we're putting on more
weight um so it's a dollar 68 per head
per day on average to to get from 575
pounds to 855 pounds at 2.8 pounds per
day and you see here here's the ration
uh you know a lot of silage corn being
being in this ration as well as legume
hay and
some corn and ddgs
the budget here and the profitability on
a 855 waste deer or putting on 2.8
pounds from 575 to 855 is a fairly
strong
proposition we have decent decent
profitability numbers at 65 per head
and that's at that average daily gain of
2.8 pounds per day basically signifying
that being on feed less time
uh while still putting on the weight
actually pays
as far as steers go and even though the
feed cost is is significantly higher at
a dollar 68 per day because we're
putting on more weight they're only on
feed for 100 days instead of
approximately 167
and under that scenario we wind up with
a situation where we have uh
essentially a much stronger return and
65 dollars per head so
it just shows here that that
again as has been in previous
presentations or renditions of this that
i've done
in different scenarios and feed costs in
years past that it just shows that
putting on weight faster tends to be a
much more profitable proposition for uh
producers uh than than than leaving them
out there for a longer period of time as
yardage costs wind up
eating up a lot of the gains
so here's our final steer scenario and
this is basically taking them from a
calf at 575 pounds all the way out to
pretty much a fat
uh calf
and just about ready to do be
slaughtered and and this is a much
faster rate again at 3.6 pounds per day
and of course for that reason you're
looking at dollars and thirty two
dollars and thirty one cents per per uh
per head per day to to put on that kind
of weight
with a much of the ration coming from
silage corn and uh corn uh grain as well
as some ddgs and grass hay
but this is the the ration for for this
scenario
now
this is the the spreadsheet that comes
out there and you'll note
that despite the
higher
cost per day and the longer time on feed
because this animal is going to be on
feed for 95 days longer than the
previous example
uh even though we're putting on more uh
more weight per day we're just flat out
putting on more weight so it's going to
stay in the yard a lot longer and this
this
basically pays out to 85 and 43 cents uh
per head
so
again a decent amount of profit to be
made backgrounding this steer to to
basically all the way to finish
you'd be looking at making 85.43 ahead
approximately but it's also worth
mentioning the longer they're on feed
even though we're putting on the weight
then you run the risk of things like
feed costs changing or livestock markets
changing because under these scenarios
remember i'm assuming a fixed
fat cattle price
and
200 days from now fat cattle prices
could change they could be better or
they obviously could be worse so
somebody may be looking at this as a as
a possibility might want to go ahead and
use some of the the revenue protection
products buy a futures contract or
something like that
in order to uh
take advantage of the prices as they are
and ensure that there aren't going to be
any losses
so our next set of scenarios the three
that we're going to talk about here are
heifer feeding scenarios
and
these follow along similar lines to the
three steer scenarios we had with some
slight modifications
so here are the prices that are used for
the heifer feeding scenarios and they're
pulled from the same auction report
looking at uh feeder heifers
all the way from you know 300 pounds up
to a thousand pounds i don't have a
a fat heifer price on here because i do
not do a a finishing heifer uh scenario
uh in in any of the three that that
you'll see going forward
so the first scenario being done is 450
pounds so lightweight heifers up to 750
pounds at a relatively low average daily
gain you know the lower end of the
steers at that 1.8 pounds per day
and a good share of this ration coming
from silage and and a good share coming
from grass hay and that comes out to a
dollar 29.30 per day
to put on this 1.8 pounds on our heifers
from 450 pounds to 756.
so to achieve
uh or arrive from 450 to 756 pounds at
1.8 pound per day that animal is going
to have to be on feed for about 170 days
so quite a long time on feed for these
these heifers here almost as long as
finishing out a steer
all the way from 550 to to 1270
something pounds
uh at 3.6 pounds but you'll notice down
here a positive return of 36.18
despite the fact that they're in the lot
for quite a while at 170 days and this
feed cost and of course yardage fees
wind up adding up day after day after
day
but what we're seeing is that as far as
heifers go even in the in the least
or the slowest rate of gain scenario
that that's being done from the lighter
weight lightest weight up to 750 pounds
still a profitable endeavor and when
we're covering all of our costs here and
and and netting 36 dollars per head so
that's a that's a pretty strong return
out the gate and i've done this uh
presentation or similar for for the last
several years and typically this
this particular scenario is not really a
money maker per se or it hasn't been in
the past but it is this year and one of
the big reasons is that price gap
between steers and heifers when you go
from
550 weight up to 700 or 800 pounds is it
almost goes away i mean 800 850 weight
750 weight heifers are selling for
almost as much in a lot of cases as the
similar weighted steers so that price
gap closing
significantly you're winding up making
making up a lot of ground financially by
by putting that weight on so not only
are you making money putting on some of
the weight the cattle buyers are looking
for right now but you're also making
money by closing that price gap between
steers and heifers so even even the
this scenario here which which typically
i've done in the past has not yielded a
positive return it is this year at 36
dollars and 18 cents per per head on
average
so our next scenario it's the similar
it's the same daily rate of gain at 1.8
pounds per day but we're starting with
550 weight heifers up to 850 weight
instead of 450 to 750 like the last
scenario again though using
relying heavily on silage for our feed
and grass hay as well with a little bit
of
ddgs in this case
for a daily cost of a dollar 39 let's
call it a dollar 40
per day to put on that kind of weight
under this scenario
so
basically we are
putting on the same amount of weight 300
pounds
at the same average daily gain so that
these animals are going to be on feed
pretty much the same amount of time as
the previous scenario 170 days
but you'll notice
that the the feed cost does change but
look at our uh return to labor and
management going from uh what it was
36 37 maybe up to 40 dollars per head
all the way up to nearly 100 per head
and the reason why is the amount that's
being paid by cattle buyers for these
850 weight animals that price is really
strong on heifers 850 weight heifers
where the price gap between heifers and
steers is pretty much gone entirely and
so with strong prices for 850 weight
calves uh it's really it's really
reflected here in this return of a
hundred dollars per head so we are
making some money
on on on putting on on the feed on the
the feed end of things but really a lot
of this money a lot of these returns are
coming from that price uh that strong
price for 800 850 weight heifers
as well as steers for that matter but
that's that's really where the strength
in this is coming from and showing that
uh this year uh
compared to all others is an outstanding
year really to be backgrounding your
heifers uh and taking advantage of what
the market is telling you and what the
market is saying is that uh feedlots
finishers uh they're really wanting
these 800 850 weight caps that's that's
what they're they're all looking for and
uh they're willing to pay for it and it
just shows right here
so the final scenario uh doing with uh
half dealing with heifers and the final
scenario of the of the presentation is
heifers from 525 pounds to 805
at a at a more rapid rate of gain at 2.8
pounds per day so a pound more than than
the previous two scenarios
and this
again will be a little bit more
expensive per day to do because we're
putting on more weight relying heavily
still on silage some corn and grass hay
and then and then a bit of ddgs as well
for this scenario
and here's how this particular scenario
shakes out you can see that uh the
animal is on feed for fewer days instead
of 170 it's down to 100 because we're
putting on putting on the weight faster
the beginning value the sales prices are
slightly different uh and the feed cost
is higher
but you'll know that the return to labor
and management is actually uh the
highest of all three scenarios in this
case
uh
this showing that putting on the weight
uh faster does in fact pay
okay
and
and you'll notice that the the risk of
keeping of this particular scenario is
probably lower because they're on feed
for fewer days so you're making just as
much money as you did in the last
scenario but not having it but keeping
them in the yard 70 fewer days so you if
you think of it from a risk
standpoint it's less riskier the long
the fewer days you have them less
susceptible to changes in feed prices
because again as i make these scenarios
uh we're assuming consistent corn prices
consistent cattle prices consistent well
feed across the board
consistent shipping costs etc etc etc
and if any of those
you know take a turn for the worse in
other words feed costs go up or cattle
prices decline
a lot of this is is going to change um
and so uh the the the the faster that
we're able to turn this the the more
likely this is to come true unless
you're taking advantage of some of these
uh these these price protection type of
type of avenues that our producers have
but you can see here this is a really
strong indicator that that
backgrounding heifers this year is is a
is a there's a there's demand for it
there's demand for animals that
at that 800 to 850 pound range and that
that again that finishers are looking
for for weight being on the animals that
they're buying
so here are the six
the six scenarios that were put together
and uh just comparing them all side by
side in terms of how many days they were
on feed the profit and loss total per
head
okay and then the dollars per day profit
or loss in in the one case and here we
see that this this final heifer scenario
the 2.8 pounds per day with 100 days on
feed
that's a really strong profit margin
making
about a dollar per day per head
that they're out there
so that's that's one of the better uh
scenarios that i have
and you'll notice that while you do make
about as much money at 1.8 pounds per
day in in terms of uh
total profit per head uh the the the
dollars per day is quite different and
that's simply because of how many days
you have to keep them to get them to 100
uh
850 pounds at 1.8 pounds per day versus
getting them to 805 pounds at 2.8 pounds
per day so you can see that that daily
uh
amount of profit for the for the 2.8
pound scenario the 525 weight to 805
weight that's a that's a pretty strong
indicator that that folks are paying for
our producers or backgrounders to put
weight on the animals themselves
and steers again
you know they're they're pretty strong
there's a strong draw to do that too
it's just that we you got to kind of be
pick pick the correct scenario to to
operate under and in this case the
best dollar per day scenario is 2.8
pounds per day from 575 weight to 855
weight which gets you about 67 cents per
day on your steers
for a total per head of 65 dollars now
feeding them all the way out to finish
does make the most money per head on in
in the case of steers at 85.43
per head but the dollars per day is 44
cents because they're on feed for so
long you know 195 days
so
you do make
total total profit per annuals higher
but your profit per day is lower and
then again you got to think about the
risk in the in the 575 to 855 weight
category they're only on feed for 100
days in the in the 575 to finish it's
it's an extra 95 days to be out there to
run the risk of death loss and shrink
and all kinds of weather issues that may
slow the rate and and caught and wind up
digging into your profits a little bit
not to mention market situations and
conditions that can that can change this
too
so the key points and the key takeaways
that i kind of want folks to think about
in in this uh from this presentation is
that essentially cattle buyers are
paying for weight uh they are they're
looking at uh 550 weight animals versus
800 850 weight or even 750 pound animals
and saying you know we're willing to pay
up for these heavier calves simply
because there's less risk uh
corn feed prices are relatively high
right now i would rather get my lot full
of uh animals that are closer to to
being
taken to market to to being fat
essentially so i'm willing to pay
and the price gap on heifers and steers
closes pretty remarkably when you go
from those 500 and 500 pound animals up
to 850 it almost disappears entirely and
it makes backgrounding heifers this year
extremely attractive one one of the more
attractive options
in recent memory
is
or at least since i've been doing these
uh comparisons that
if there was a year to background
heifers and put the weight on as quickly
as you could this is definitely one of
them
again a lot of things can happen in
markets and so you know if you're going
to do this it may
may pay to take advantage of some of the
pricing options available
to you
but right now it definitely looks like
something that if you have the means to
do it
money can be made
putting weight on and back grounding
and then a few more key points uh
putting on weight fast still pays
even even at 5.75 corn and higher hay
prices
it seems like
no matter
i i don't want to say no matter what i'm
sure we can find some situations where
that's not the case
but
it seems like that putting on weight
faster typically winds up paying more
and and part of it's a function of how
these budgets are set up
because what winds up happening is
yardage fees
eat into your daily profits pretty
quickly and if you're keeping track of
your own time
wear and tear on machinery
other labor costs if you have any kind
of paid labor utility bills
etc etc wear and tear on your
facilities the longer the animals are in
there the more of that those costs add
up and so if if you're making money on
feed
it is always going to pay more to to
you know if your feed if your returns on
feed or are positive just just wait
versus feed it's always going to pay
more to to basically put the weight on
faster that's just kind of what these
scenarios show and and what's been true
for the last several years that and and
even when when i've shown a loss the
loss is smaller when you put on weight
faster that's just that's been the case
and and right now it is certainly true
as has been in the past
well i want to thank everyone for
watching hopefully you were able to get
something out of this presentation that
helps you with any decisions that you
might have been pondering or thinking
about going from you know this fall
headed into next spring as far as
background in calves or selling selling
out right right away
you can see my email address is right
there on the on the screen if you have
any questions about this presentation or
something you want clarification of i'd
be happy to answer any questions that i
can so thanks again for watching and i
hope you all stay warm this winter thank
you